这个应该是在后背
后面
这个是前面
圆领圆领
这个上面有点微狭
有一个线接口的地方
看没一丢丢
我妈呀
还贴了个标
来尺寸量一下
来
胸围
长度
长度是111
111的长度
这个
这个有要的扣
来这个20
19扣2
这里有一点点
这里贴了个标
这里是应该是接口
一个粗杀线有一点点
不介意的扣2
扣2
面料很垂这个圈
19块
均绿色
均绿色的
扣2
,
这个领口的话是一个墨尔花边领的
这一款
很粉色和蓝色格子的
来胸围
胸围110120110120的胸围
长度
长度53
这个19
19扣个5
全棉100
原来49的
修口的话是一个全松拧的
修口是一个小松拧
19块
全棉100
扣5
19扣个5
来这一款
这个是连帽的
连帽的这一款
前面有个大口袋的这一款
卫衣
大口袋的这一款
卫衣好大一个
来胸围
胸围134
来长度
长度70
这个29
扣6
29块
扣个6
来这一款
这个是个
半高领的一款针织打底
然后这个上面还是这种带一点点小镂空的这种
薄的很看到没
有一点小镂空
这个单穿当打底都好
胸围86106
86106来一场
一场51
这个有要的19
尺码小的很
19扣个1
给你们一个福利
1919扣1扣1
看看上面有一点这种
这种小镂空呢
拿这样子的
19给你们了
扣1扣1
尺码小
19块扣个1
尺码小的
19扣2
19扣3
19扣4
19扣5
19扣6
19扣7
19扣8
19扣9
19扣11
19扣12
19扣13
19扣14
19扣15
19扣16
19扣17
19扣18
19扣19
19扣21
19扣22
19扣23
19扣24
19扣25
19扣26
19扣27
19扣28
19扣30
19扣31
19扣32
19扣33
19扣44
19扣46
19扣47
19扣48
19扣49
19扣51
19扣53
19扑54
19扑55
19扑56
19扑57
19扑58
19扑59
19扑60
19扑61
19扑62
19扑63
19扑64
19扑65
19扑67
19扑68
来这个一款
来这个是一个
藏蓝色刚刚过到一个粉色
刚刚过到一个粉色
但是那个上面有瑕疵
上面写字了
这个藏蓝色这个上面没写
没有写字哦
来这个胸纹
胸纹的话是104 116
104 116
来这个长度
长度103
这个39扣3
39块扣3扣3
断面断面的这个是
39扣3
藏蓝色的一个连接圈
这样子的
39块扣3扣3
39扣个3
39扣3
来
这个是全棉一版的一个衬衣
格子拨点条纹拼接
来
胸纹104 114
长度69
9块扣9扣9
9块扣个9扣个9
9块扣个9
来这个
蓝白条
藏蓝色蓝白条的一款打底
和刚刚那个灰色是一个款
前围后围的这个
来
胸围
胸围110 134
110 134
长度
长度60 68的长度
这个9块扣8
9块扣8
蓝白条的一个打底
9块扣个8
来这个背鞋这只裙
后面有松拧
但是这个带子没有了
本来是有这个绑带的
这个绑带没有了
给你们放负力了一块
来
胸围90 102 90 102
来这个长度
长度是118
这个29扣8
29 29扣8扣8
29块扣个8
放个负力
好的也有
格子衬衣
格子衬衣全棉的
棉100
是这个不
全棉100的
身上的上衣没有欠的
那我自己的
我自己的没有了
这个棉100
棉100
无关心的
全棉全棉的
看喜标还有不
这个喜标没有了
能穿是吧
OK来
378无关心动
9块钱
9块好的
谢谢
378 378谢谢
你检查一下
好
谢谢
这个是个大围巾吧
应该是
看看
沙棉的一样的
看薄的很
边边是这种小流缩
特别柔软
这么宽
你看这么宽
长度很长
这个
来这个九块
九块扣个一
九块九块扣一扣一
大围巾
双层这么大
这么长
薄的很
棉呢棉呢
就像沙棉一样的
九块九块
来小小
给你了
一位是块布
围巾
大围巾
布也划算
这么好的布
还可以做件衣服呢
好
谢谢
没有那个啥了
我去拿包装袋去
án
冬装
就是双层
然后
我去买一个
下午
我拿过来
跟给对面我
冬装
就是用一个
是中性布
还是泡泡
是泡泡
这个
可以放 放在
收紧
然后
确保
这个
个
就
把
找
就是
就
放在
你
店里
里面
就
冰
就可以
铃
冰
OK
这个
喜欢
你
我买过小的那一款
对吧
小的那个还是个高货了
你还记得不
有一个拼件
蓝色那个是高货的
很好很好的
软了没
来这一款
这个是没有扣没有扣眼
嗯
镂空的这个外搭又出来了
外搭又出来了
这个胸围是120-140的
长度是113
9块钱
扣3扣3
9块扣个3
9块9块
扣3扣3
蓝白条的
是一个小短袖
这个原来有个长袖的
这个9块钱
扣3扣3
9块扣个3扣个3
来这个小吊带
小吊带
这个标道是一个
M码M码
来这一款尺寸量一下
胸围
胸围是80能拉伸到96
来这个长度
长度53
来这个29扣3
29块扣3扣3
29扣个3扣个3
拜拜我该走了
我也要下班了
终于熬了一天
我得快饶了
这一颗杂声
明天见明天见早点来陪我
拜拜姐妹们
下午好姐妹们
无关心动下午好下午好
笑容抑制不住
那肯定了下班了还能不高兴吗
来这个威领
A&Y他们家的
这个是一个调牌价要9000多
将近1万块钱左右的下午好姐妹们
来这一款原价咱们是要卖59的
这个现在给大家的是福利价19
我来量一下
胸围98102
腰围70自己拉到82
我这给你个小人
那个是你要懂的
我把它选定了
长度113长度113下午好
来这款谁要19
1919谁要谁来扣个1
来小姐姐们
小妹妹妹19扣1
19扣个1
来喜欢的姐姐衣服
1919超级划算
超级划算
19扣1
来这一款是一个卫衣
圆领的可以一字领的圆领的这一款卫衣粉色粉色
有没有小姨妈的那个裙子是不是
啊
我再给你看
有的时候会小一点
我再给你拿一条给你量一下
我打了两次
大家的裙
这个没挂吗
爆款居然没挂
我再去给你拿一条
这里有这里有
我给你拿一个
这有刚好有一种
我跟你量一下
有群的时候爆感
这个胸围的话
平铺96可以吗
96可以拉伸到100
腰围的话
其实可以拉伸到90
70 90
寻常的话是112
这个可以吗
92 96
94 96的
可以吗
19穿出来可好看了
穿出来可好看了
前面是一个装饰的
有好多老粉姐姐都拍了
我跟你说轩轩姐姐
也得买了得有10条
她送人
因为这个太划算了
又好看
价格又有划算
只要19块可以好的
谢谢
开张了开张了大吉
今天开的早
谢谢你
我必须给你找个小礼物送给你
帮我开张的都得有礼物
这个这个圈的你为啥子咋了
这个你为啥子咋了
他腰弹个谁
那个啥意思是不是
写个19咋的
那个鱼
鱼
对啊
那个鱼是在19块
我以为我以为在
一直都在29的
你问我啥
我自己的我还不知道的
我我我
我以为说29
好
谢谢啊
321送你一个黑的小背心
啊
让那个椅子都在29了
那个椅子都在29